[موسيقى]
اقدم لكم نشره التاسعه هذا المساء اليكم
العناوين
اداره بايدن توربكو اوكرانيا تطالبها
بهجوم مضاد ضد روسيا وتبلغها باحتمال
انقطاع المساعدات العسكريه عنها
اثناء تفاقده اثار الزلزال في تركيا
بلينكين يؤكد العقوبات لن تؤثر على وصول
المساعدات للسوريين
[موسيقى]
النظام الايراني يعيد نصب المشانق لقمع
المحتجين ويعدم معتقلين بلوشيين من زاهده
وبعد ساعه من الضربه على دمشق نتنياهو
يحذر طهران لن نسمح بوجودكم على الحدود
الشماليه لاسرائيل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم نبدا تفاصيل التاسعه هذا المساء
مشاهدينا من ملف الحرب في اوكرانيا التي
تقترب من الذكرى الاولى بعد ايام قليله
حيث طالبت واشنطن بتعزيز مكاسبها والتحضير
بشكل جيد لشن هجوم مضاد ضد القوات الروسيه
وبينما دعتها لهجوم مضاد اربكت الولايات
المتحده حليفتها اوكرانيا بتصريح مفاجئ في
ذات الوقت مشيره الى انها قد تقطع عنها
المساعدات العسكريه
بمجرد ان يصوت الجمهوريون على ذلك وهو امر
غير مستبعد ابدا سيما مع سيطره الجمهوريين
على مجلس النواب بدورها دعت استونيا الى
ضروره تقديم روسيا للعداله لمحاسبتها على
جرائم الحرب التي ارتكبتها في اوكرانيا
قال البعض كما تعلمون لا يمكن ان يكون من
دول مثل دول البلطيق لانه سيثير استفزاز
روسيا لكن بعد ذلك تقول في الواقع اذا كان
هذا صحيحا اولا وقبل كل شيء لا اعتقد ان
علاقتنا مع روسيا يمكن ان تزداد سوءا مما
هي عليه الان لانه يشن حربا في اوكرانيا
والثاني هو انك تقول في الواقع اننا نمنح
بوتين السلطه ليقرر من يستطيع ومن لا
يمكنه على سبيل المثال الامين العام لحلف
النيتو ثم في الواقع تمنحه قوه اكبر مما
لديه
في ارسال اسلحه الى روسيا لاستخدامها في
اوكرانيا واضافها بلينكن في تصريحات نيوز
ان الشركات الصينيه تدعم بالفعل تقدم دعما
ماديا لروسيا وتشير للمعلومات الجديده الى
ان يمكن ان تقدم ايضا دعما بالسلاح الى
روسيا وحذر وزير الخارجيه الامريكي من ان
هذا التصعيد سيتسبب في عواقب وخيمه على
الصين
اما في بكين فيزور غدا الاثنين كبير
الدبلوماسيين الصينيين موسكو بعد جوله
اوروبيه اعلن خلالها خطه صينيه للسلام في
اوكرانيا ووفقا للمتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الصينيه فان زياره وانجي لروسيا
ستوفر فرصه للبلدين لمواصله تطوير الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه وتبادل وجهات النظر حول
القضايا الدوليه والاقليميه ذات الاهتمام
المشترك ولم تحدد وزاره الخارجيه ما اذا
كان كبير الدبلوماسيين الصينيين سيلتقي
بالرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
اوروبيا اعلن وزير الجيوش الفرنسيه
ان بلاده ستسلم اوكرانيا الدبابات
القتاليه الخفيفه اي ام اكس 10 نهايه
الاسبوع المقبل وفي مقابله مع صحيفه اكد
وزير الجيوش الفرنسيه انه لن يذكر عدد
الدبابات حتى لا يعطي معلومات استراتيجيه
لروسيا على حد قوله من جهه اخرى اشارنيه
الى ان تدريب الاوكرانيين على هذه المعدات
الجديده على وشك الانتهاء حول امكانيه
تسليم اوكرانيا طائرات حربيه مقاتله قال
انه لا شيء محظور لكنه اشار في الوقت ذاته
الى تعقيد المسائل اللوجستيه والعمليه ولم
يستبعد وزير الجيوش الفرنسيه تدريب طيارين
كما تفعل بريطانيا
قالت الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه ان القوات
النوويه الاستراتيجيه الروسيه اجرت
مناورات واسعه تزامنا مع زياره رئيس
الامريكي لاوروبا واعتبر اوكرانيا ان
المناورات الروسيه هدفنا اضعاف الدعم
الدولي لاوكرانيا ومنع زياره بايدن
المقرره غدا لاوروبا واوضحت الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه ان القوات النوويه الروسيه
استعدت برا وبحرا وجوا واجرت فحصا لنظام
التحكم القتالي اضافه لصواريخ كروس
وفي ميدانيات الحرب افاد اعلام الروسي
المشاهدين باجلاء السكان من ضواحي ضخمه
بسبب قصف اوكرانيا فيما اعلن عمده مدينه
دنيتك المؤيد لروسيا عن ايقاف عمل
المواصلات العامه في مدينه دنيتك تحسبا
لتطورات القصف الاوكراني بعد استهداف
مناطق متفرقه من المدينه باربعين صاروخ
فامباير تشيكيا وخمس قذائف ام كما شمل
القصف مدافع واسفر عن اصابه شخصين واضرار
ماديه
هي من ستحدد هويه المنتصر في هذه الحرب
بين روسيا واوكرانيا وفقا لصحيفه يوزويك
الامريكيه التي كشفت ان معركه باخم تقترب
من نقطه لا عوده حيث تتصاعد الاشتباكات
حول المدينه قبل هجوم جديد متوقع من روسيا
هذا الربيع لكن لماذا اصبحت المدينه
الصناعيه الصغيره نقطه حرجه في هذه الحرب
ولماذا فشلت روسيا الى الان في السيطره
عليها رغم مشاركه مرتزقه فاجنر فيها يجيب
مسؤولون غربيون لنيوزويك بان الروس يريدون
استخدام بعد الاستيلاء عليها كنقطه انطلاق
نحو هدفها المتمثل في الاستيلاء على منطقه
دومباس باكملها والامر ذاته دافع كبير
لكيف هي الاخرى ورئيس هازنسكي الذي يعتبر
الانتصار في ضخمه انتصارا لكل اوكرانيا
سيما وانها باتت تشكل رمزا للمقاومه
الاوكرانيه وانها ستكون نقطه انطلاق هجوم
مضاد لكيف وفقا لنيوزويك دائما
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا كل هذا ومعركه الجو لم تبدا
بعد واوكرانيا وروسيا تتحضران لها مع
اقتراب الذكرى السنويه الاولى للحرب وفق
صحيفه التايمز البريطانيه وهنا لابد لنا
اذا مشاهدينا من التعرف على قوه السلاح
الجوي الروسيه الذي لم تستخدمه موسكو رغم
مروري عام على الحرب نتحدث اذا عن القوه
الجويه الروسيه التي تحتل المرتبه الثانيه
على مستوى العالم من حيث عدد الطائرات
والافراد العاملين بعد القوه الجويه
الامريكيه فلنتعرف على اهم المقاتلات
الروسيه تمتلك روسيا مشاهدينا العديد من
المقاتلات الحديثه والتي تتمتع ايضا
بقدرات التخفي عن شاشات الرادار منها
مقاتلات سو سبعه وخمسين الحديثه وكذلك
مقاتلات سوق 57 الحديث كذلك والمقاتله
ايضا
بالاضافه الى طرز متنوعه ومختلفه اخرى
لدينا كذلك سبعه وخمسين تعتبر
من احوسيه المقاتله وتاتي بتصميم شبيه
بباقي مقاتلات الصخوري لكنها مزوده بخاصيه
الاختفاء وهي نسخه مطوره عن طائرات الجيل
الرابع وهي تطوير كذلك لطائره سوخوي خمسه
على ذكر هذه الطائره دعونا نتعرف عليها
ونشاهدها هنا صحوي 35 اذا تمثل هذه
المقاتله نسخه محدثه ومطوره من سوخوي سبعه
وعشرين وهي طائره متقدمه من طائرات الجيل
الرابع لكنها ليست من الجيل الخامس بحسب
خبراء عسكريين غربيين ويمكن تزويد الطائره
باسلحه تصل زينتها الى اكثر من ثمانيه
الاف كلغ نذهب الى طائره اخرى هي طائره
ميغ 31 بام هذه الطائره الروسيه تشكل
العمود الفقري لسلاح الجو الروسي وتتمتع
بمزايا دفاعيه متقدمه وقدرات على مهاجمه
اهداف بريه معاديه كذلك الى جانب سرعتها
الفائقه والتحليق على ارتفاعات عاليه جدا
لكن مشاهدينا ورغم هذه المقاتلات المتطوره
لدى موسكو الا ان الاخيره تتردد كثيرا في
استخدامها والسبب هنا بحسب خبراء ان هذه
المقاتلات المتطوره تستخدم ذخيره سوفياتيه
قديمه وبالتالي يتطلب الامر ان تطير على
علو منخفض لتصيب تلك الذخائر اهدافها
كونها قديمه الطراز والامر الذي يعرضها
لخطر الرادارات والمضادات الاوكرانيه
اذا نبدا في المتابعه مع مراسلين نذهب الى
كيف معنا من هناك حذيفه عادل حذيفه اهلا
بك معنا بدايه كيف تلقت اكياد هذه الرساله
رساله واشنطن ببدء الهجوم المضاد قبل
معركه الربيع وكذلك الاحاديث حول احتماليه
قطع المساعدات العسكريه عنها
تحياتي صهيب في الحقيقه في اطار تغطيه هذه
القضيه ومتابعه هذا الموضوع تحديدا قرات
تعليقات لخبراء عسكريين ومراقبين هي جديره
بالاهتمام حول ما اذا كان هذه التصريحات
من قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وحتى
التصريحات التي تصدر منك باستعجال الامداد
العسكري ونقص الذخيره وما الى ذلك انه
يعني في ذات اتجاه الخدعه في الحرب وان
كييف وعمليه التوصيل
الاسلحه والمعدات هي جاريه بالفعل وهنالك
تنسيق دقيق بين النيتو وبين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وبين اوكرانيا وجاري
فعلا عمليه توصيل الاسلحه الى داخل
الاراضي الاوكرانيه ويستشهدون في ذلك طبعا
بالهجوم المضاده الذي قامت به اوكرانيا في
استعاده السيطره على خارك عندما كان
الاعلان عن استعاده السيطره في اخرسون
ولكن على ايه حال الم عنه الان انه في
الاسبوع القادم سوف تبدا فرنسا
بتسليم الدبابات اي ام اكس عشره وكذلك
ينهي الجنود الاوكرانيه للتدريباتهم في
الاسابيع القليله القادمه ومع ذلك تبدا
عمليه توصيل الدبابات والاسلحه الموعوده
بها
وزير الجيوش الفرنسي اذن ابقى معنا حذيفه
ينضم الينا الان مراسلنا في دنيا الاغبر
رائد مرحبا بك معنا بدايه كان هناك اليوم
قصف على التفاصيل لو سمحت
صهيب بالفعل يعني عاده القوات الاوكرانيه
لتقصف قلب المدينه او العاصمه دانيتك قتيل
واحد عشر اصابه حصيله القصف لهذا اليوم
والقصف استهدف مناطق مختلفه مدنيه وحكوميه
بالفعل 45 صاروخ وقذيفه مره واحده اربعين
صاروخ جراد او فامبير التشيكيه وبولنديه
صنع استهدفت قلب المدينه وخمسه قذائف من
عيار 155 وهي
القذائف الامريكيه التي تطلق من مدافع
هاوزر بالفعل رغم الحديث عن ضعف الامكانات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه خلال الفتره الماضيه
بالذخيره اي ان المستودعات باتت خاويه
وخاليه من الذخيره عاده اليوم اوكرانيا
لتقصف من جديد المناطق المدنيه ايضا هناك
عمليات الاجلاء على اطراف المقاطعه حول
باخمه يعني صرح عمده المدينه بانه تتم
عمليات اجلاء للمدنيين المقيمين في
البلدات المتاخمه لباخمت وايضا من الناحيه
الغربيه اي في وسط باخموت ايضا هناك
عمليات اجلاء للاوكرانيين للناحيه
الاوكرانيه لابد ان هناك شيء ما كبير يحضر
له عمليه عسكريه كبيره حول
النقطه فعلا رائد ساودي اليك في مساله ما
الشيء الذي يحضر له ولكن لن يسالك حذيفه
تحدثت عن الدبابات الفرنسيه التي ستبدا في
الوصول الى اوكرانيا وكذلك هذه المطالبه
الامريكيه للاوكرانيين ببدء هجوم مضاد
حدثني عن باخمت ماذا تقول بان هذه المعركه
هي مهمه جدا في حسم هذه المعركه هذه الحرب
ماذا تقول اوكرانيا عن وضع قواتها المدافع
عن باخموت وهل هناك استعدادات اوكرانيه
فعلا لبدء هجوم مضاد ضد ما تحضر له روسيا
اولا صهيب اوكرانيا تستخدم باخموت لتعطيل
جيش الاتحاد الروسي من التقدم حتى وصول
الامدادات هذا تصريح واضح من القاده
العسكريين حول انه لم يسمحوا بدخول على
الرغم من ان الشركاء الغربيين والمستشعرين
الغربيين نصحوا كيف بيع الانسحاب نسبه
للذخيره الهائله والكبيره التي يستخدمها
الجيش الاوكراني للصد الهجمات القويه من
قبل الاتحاد الروسي لكن اليوم يعني اذا
تحدثنا عن قائد كتيبه الاستطلاعات
الاستطلاع في
نشر فيديو على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
تحدث بشكل واضح عن ان الوضع صعب جدا وقاسي
جدا وان الهجوم من الجهات الثلاث من الشرق
ومن الجنوب ومن الشمال تبقى الجهه الغربيه
فقط التي لا تقوم القوات الروسيه بشن
هجمات منها ولكنه ايضا اكد ان الدفاعات
الهندسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه قادره على سد
اي هجمات وان القوات الروسيه لن تدخل الى
هذه المدينه في الوقت الحالي وهم مطمئنون
لذلك
رائد ماذا عنك هناك حديث عن استعدادات
تحشيد عسكري كبير جدا روسي في دونيسك
وايضا بنسبه اقل فيروجيا ما حقيقه هذا
يعني بالفعل صهيب تعتبر منطقه دانياتكيا
الاكثر سخونه
وتشهد معارك ضاريه على حدودها الجنوبيه
وشماليه حيث اجلادار في الجنوب في الشمال
باخموت هناك حضور كبير واعداد كبير من
جنود الذين قدموا من موسكو بعد التعبئه
الجزئيه التي اعلنت اواخر العام الماضي
بالفعل هناك حضور لسلاح الجو الروسي في
المنطقه دخول مقاتلات حديثه دخول دبابات
حديثه متطوره صواريخ نسمع اصوات ذوي
انفجارات مختلفه اقصد اطلاق النار من
القذائف والمدافع الروسيه الدوي مختلف عن
ما كنا نسمعه مع بدايه المعارك خلال العام
الماضي بالفعل دخلت اسلحه جديده في نطاق
العمليه العسكريه يعني موازاه او تزامنا
مع الدعم المنتظر القوات الاوكرانيه في
المنطقه الشماليه من دانيسك وهي باخمه حيث
هناك تتم كما اسلفت لك عمليات اجلاء من
الطرفين الجانب الروسي والجانب الاوكراني
للسكان المدنيين وهذه اشاره كبيره الى ان
هناك معركه داميه ستكون في تلك المنطقه في
مدينه باقمت او حولها من دونيت كوكييف
مراسله العربيه شكرا جزيلا لكما رائد
الاخبار وحذيفه عادل
عجله الحرب في اوكرانيا لا تتوقف عن
الدوران فصول اربعه عاشتها المعركه في
انتظار فصل خامس
كيف تستعد لصد هجوم روسي محتمل خلال
الربيع
هجوم يسبقه تكتيك روسي جديد يتمثل في
اطلاق مناطيد تحمل عاكسات رادار فوق
اوكرانيا للحصول على معلومات بشان انظمه
الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني لاجبار كييف على
استنزاف مخزوناتها القيمه من الذخيره
وصواريخ ارض جو حسب الدفاع البريطانيه
لمواجهه ذلك الاوكرانيون فتحوا خطه تعبئه
طوعيه جديده وفق صحيفه الطاعنز الصحيفه
ذاتها نقلت عن مستشار زيلينسكي قوله ان
معركه السيطره على باخموت مهمه وان
اوكرانيا لن تتخلى عنها ابدا اذ تعتبرها
مفتاح الصراع ولا مجال لخسارتها فالسيطره
على باخموت ستشكل نقطه انطلاق بالنسبه
لروسيا للزحف نحو مدينتين اكبر هما اكرم
تورس كواس لوفيسك اللتين تقعان ابعد
باتجاه الغرب في دونيتسك ما سيعيد الزخم
قبل الذكرى الاولى لانطلاق الحرب ولتحقيق
هذا الهدف تطالب اوكرانيا حلفائها
الغربيين بالمزيد من الطائرات المقاتله
والدبابات الحربيه المتقدمه في وقت تؤكد
كياف انها تحتاج ايضا صواريخ بعيده المدى
لصد الهجوم الروسي واستعاده السيطره على
المناطق التي خسرتها فالجيش الاوكراني
يستهلك القذائف بوتيره اسرع مما يمكن
للغرب ان يصنع حسب رويترز ما يمثل عقبه
اخرى امام قوتكياف خلال المرحله المقبله
بلال الوجداني العربيه
نتابع في التاسع ولكن بعد الفاصل
البرهان يوقع مع سلفاكير مليارديت على
نسخه جديده للاتفاق جبال السلام
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد نستكمل التاسع هذا
المساء مشاهدينا من تركيا وسوريا والكارثه
التي تسبب بها الزلزال الذي ضرب البلدين
[موسيقى]
في ملف الكارثه التي خلفها زلزال بسوريا
وتركيا افادت اداره الكوارث التركيه
بارتفاع حصيله قتل الزلزال الى اكثر من
اربعين الف شخص واوضحت اداره الكوارث
التركيه ان عمليات البحث والانقاذ انتهت
في معظم المناطق المنكوبه بالزلزال مشيره
الى انها ما زالت متواصله في كرمان مراش
هذا واشارت وكاله الاناضول التركيه الى
اعتقال نحو 131 شخصا على خلفيه التحقيق في
بناء مبان مخالفه وانهيارها في كرمان مراش
جراء الزلزال العنيف الذي ضرب جنوبي تركيا
وفقا للمعلومات الاوليه تم تحديد مسؤوليات
430 مشتبها بهم في التحقيقات التي بداها
مكتب المدعي العام التركي وحسب وكاله
الاناضول التركيه دائما تبين ان 11 شخصا
من المشتبه بهم ليسوا على قيد الحياه
وخمسه اخرون خارج البلاد فيما تم الافراج
عن 54 اخرين بعد التحقيق معهم
وعلى مستوى الخسائر الاقتصاديه يجد الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان نفسه مضطرا الى
اصلاح اضرار بحوالي 79 مليار يورو وفق
وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه فيما تقارب
تقديرات خبراء اخرين الكلفه بتسعه مليارات
ونصف المليار دولار وتضيف رويترز انه
يتوجب على رئيس التركي تنفيذه تعهده
لاعمار احدى عشره ولايه في الجنوب والجنوب
الشرقي من البلاد لحقها دمار هائل كما وعد
اردوغان بمنح ملايين الليرات التركيه
للمواطنين المتضررين مع اقتراب الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والتشريعيه المقرره في الرابع
عشر من مايو في وقت تواجه فيه الليره
التركيه تحدي الانهيار وفق الوكاله
الدوليه
معنى مباشره من اديمان موفد العربيه محمود
شكر محمود اهلا بك معنا ما طبيعه العمليات
الجاريه في اليمن في هذه المرحله
نعم يمكن القول الى ان الشيء الذي طرا
جديدا على المحافظات والولايات التركيه هي
ان المواطنين ذهبوا ما بين الامس واليوم
الى عمليه افراغ منازلهم من الاثاث الذي
يملكونه هذه المساله لم تكن في الايام
الماضيه وهذا مشاهدناه في كثير من الاحياء
في هذه المدينه اذا راينا تجمعات لمواطنين
اتراقهم يستعملون الالات الثقيله التي تصل
الى الطوابق العاشره والحادي عشره وينزلون
الاثاث من منازلهم وكل حاجتهم لانهم
بطبيعته الحاليه ينتقلون الى اماكن اخرى
او ايضا الى قرى اخرى او ايضا الى محافظات
اخرى بالتوازي لا تزال عمليه الترحيل من
داخل المدينه الى العائلات التي تريد ان
تخرج منها هو على قدم وساقن وهذا ما
عنيناه ايضا في المخيمات بالاضافه ايضا
الى ان الجل الاكبر من الذين ابقوا في
المدينه وزعوا على المخيمات التي انتشرت
بالمئات فضلا عن المسكن الجامعي ايضا كانت
هنالك اللجان الهندسيه التي بدات بعمليات
مسح للبنيات والتي هي مرقبه منها ما هو
صالح ومنها ما هو غير صالح وبدا اعطاء
الاذونات وتحديدا للابنيه التي هي ذات
طابق او طابقين بالعوده اليها بالنسبه الى
عمليات رفع الالقاب او عمليات البحث عن
ناجين هي غائبه كليا هنا في المدينه ولكن
رفع الانقاذ بدات ولو بوتيره خفيفه خفيفه
وايضا كان هنالك رفع الانقلاب والتوقف
البحث عن نادين نعم وزير الصحه التركيه
حذر من انتشار الاوبئه خلال هذه المرحله
بالنظر طبعا الى وجود جثث منذ ايام تحت
الانقاض هل حدثنا كذلك عن الاجراءات
الصحيه كيف يتم التعامل الان مع هذا
الموضوع مع خطر الاوبئه كذلك وانتشارها
نعم هذه المساله هي تتركز ايضا في الاماكن
التي لا تزال عمليات رفع الانقاض للوصول
الى الاحياء هي قائمه وهي اتخذت اجراءات
بالنسبه للاطقم العامله ما بين الدفاع
المدني وما بين عمال المناجم وهم يدركون
ويعلمون الى ان الجثث الان في اليوم
الثالث عشر الرابع عشر هي اصبحت في نوع ما
من التحلل لذلك اخذ اجراءات من الملابس
الى الكمامات ولكن في المدينه التي نحن
نتواجد بها يرجح الظن الى ان الجثث هي
غائبه بدليل الى ان ورش الجرافات
والحفارات توقفت منذ ثلاثه ايام او من كان
عنده اقارب او اهل او اشقاء تحت الركام
كان تواصل مع السلطات في الايام الاولى او
في اخر الاسبوع الماضي والجرى العمل
لساعات طويله للوصول الى هذه الجثث اما
بالقول العام ان هنالك امران لربما ان هذا
يكون طبعا ايضا مرده لحاله المخيمات
ولحايه المرض وهي ايضا بالمناسبه اذا ظهرت
سريعا اذا امكن الى بس ساذهب معك الى هذه
الصوره هذه خيمه معده هذه التي نذهب
مباشره اليها هذه خيمه معده لتقديمه
السريعه للطبابه وللادويه وفيها فريق طبي
وفيها فريق تمريضي وايضا فيها فريق من
الصيادله نعم طيب قبل ان ينتهي الوقت فقط
محمود لفتني في كلامك ذكرت انه الناس بدات
تعود لاخذ اثاثها او بعض المقتنيات من
المنازل التي تدمرت في الزلزال
وهناك الناس التي لم تغادرهم سكنوا في
المخيمات
هناك حديث على انه الناس في المناطق
المنكوبه ربما سيهجرون مناطقهم الى الابد
سيذهبون للعيش في مناطق اخرى ما الذي
رصدته من اراء السكان هل سيعودون الى
منطقتهم في الديمان ام يعني سي اجرون الى
منطقه اخرى
هذه المدينه فيها مشكله كبيره جدا هو ان
عاصفه الزلزال قد اكلها اكلا كليا لذلك من
المنطق والمقبول والمعقول الى ان الذين
خرجوا منها لن يعودوا اليها على قاعده الى
ان الاعمار الذي سيكون بها لربما هو يحتاج
الى السنه او سنتين وايضا هنالك تغيير
ديموغرافي وسكني وجغرافي في الابنيه
والاحياء وخاصه الى ان الحكومه
ذهبت الى عمليات اقتراح او بدائل من له
شقه هنا لربما يكون له شقه في المنطقه
اخرى هذا على مستوى الاتراك حتى ايضا
النازحين السوريين الذين هم الان في
المدينه سمعت منهم الى انهم يبحثون عن
اماكن اخرى لربما قرب اسطنبول او قرب
اماكن اخرى وهنا لهم شقق استاجروها فالكل
من يستطيع ان يترك سيترك ومن يستطيع ان
يحمل معه ما استطاع سيحمل ولكن هنالك هدم
كلي سيكون لثلاثه ارباع المدينه للبناء من
جديد هل ستكون الابنيه على هنا وخاصه اذا
ان نحن نتحدث عن خط زلزالي في وسط المدينه
عصف بها عصفا كليا ام ان الابنيه كما قال
الرئيس الجمهوريه لن تكون على خط على خط
الزلزال هذا نقاش ايضا وتحدي ومساله صعبه
نتحدث هنا عن الفيء بنايه ونتحدث عن ما
يقارب 10,000 شقه مساله معقده وصعبه جدا
وبحاجه الى امكانيات وبحاجه ايضا الى وقت
وبحاجه ايضا الى خطه اين ستكون واين ستبدا
بها العمليات اعاده الاعمار نعم شكرا
جزيلا لك محمود شكر المفضل العربيه الى
اليمن ومشاهدينا نذكر اذا بالاخبار
العاجله اذا الظاهره على شاشه العربيه
دبلوماسيون يؤكدون اذا عثور واكتشاف
يورانيوم مخصب بنسبه نقاء تصل الى 84 في
الم في ايران طبعا
الوصول الى درجه نقاء 90% يمكن الوصول من
خلالها الى انتاج القنبله
النوويه اذا هذا هو العاجل اذا يؤكدون
اكتشاف هذا اليورانيوم المخصب بالنسبه 84
في المئه في ايران نعود الى ملف الزلزال
حيث قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلينكن ان الولايات المتحده ستظل ملتزمه
ببذل كل ما في وسعها لمساعده تركيا بعد
الزلزال لكن اعرب خلال زيارته الى تركيا
عن حزنه بعد رؤيه الدمار الذي خلفه
الزلزال في تركيا كذلك اكد بلنكن ان
امريكا تعمل على ضمان عدم تسبب العقوبات
على سوريا بعرقله وصول المساعدات يذكر ان
زياره بلينك الى تركيا هي الاولى له منذ
توليه لمنصبه قبل عامين
من بين الانقاض تولد الحياه نداء اممي
لرعايه الاف الحوامل بعد الزلزال صندوق
الامم المتحده للسكان كشف في تقريره ان
133 الف امراه حامل تضررت جراء الزلزال في
سوريا وافاد الصندوق بان ما يقرب من
6600 امراه سيعانين من مضاعفات الحمل
والولاده في ظل التوقعات بان تلد نحو
اربعه واربعين الف امراه في الاشهر
الثلاثه المقبله وشددت الوكاله الامميه
على الحاجه الملحه لتوفير رعايه طبيه
محترفه لهن لتلافي المخاطر الناجمه عن
الولاده والتي قد تهدد حياتهن واشار صندوق
الامم المتحده للسكان الى انه يكثف جهوده
لضمان استمرار توفير خدمات الصحه
الايجابيه المنقذه للحياه بالتعاون مع
شركائه في محافظتي حلب وادلب
[موسيقى]
نتابع من ريف ادلب مع الصحفي محمد الاشقر
محمد اهلا بك معنا في التاسعه هذا المساء
الخوذ البيضاء كانت تحدثت عن وفيات جراء
الكوليرا في شمال غرب سوريا هل لديك
المزيد من التفاصيل وجديد كذلك الوضع
الصحي والانساني والمعيشه عندكم في ريف
ادلب
نعم يعني في الحقيقه هناك مخاوف كثيره من
انتشار وباء الكوليرا في مناطق في عموم
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا خصوصا ان هناك
العديد من الوفيات التي سجلت بحسب دفاع
المدني وبعض المشافي في المنطقه طبعا هذا
المرض ليس او هذا الوباء ليس هو الوحيد
الذي يحذر منه اطلقت مناشدات عديده من
شمال غرب سوريا للخارج للاسراع بادخال
المساعدات الطبيه
والاتخاذ الاجراءات الاحترازيه من انتشار
الاوبئه والامراض في المنطقه هناك مخاوف
عديده من موضوع احتماليه وجود ضحايا تحت
الانقاض لا يزالون الى حد هذه اللحظه وان
الجثثهم بدات تتحلل وهذا الامر الذي قد
يهدد المدنيين الذين لا يزالون يعيشون في
المناطق والمدن التي تدمرت طبعا بالاضافه
للعديد من الامراض التي من الممكن ان
تنتشر في
خصوصا ان مراكز الايواء المؤقته والمخيمات
المستحدثه او حتى المخيمات المنشاه سابقا
مكتظه بالمتضررين ومقتظه بالنازحين
القدامى من المدن والبلدات في عموم مناطق
سوريا طبعا هذا بالاضافه
يعني لدرجات الحراره المتدنيه خصوصا انها
تصل في بعض الاحيان الى ناقص ثلاث درجات
او اربع درجات جميع هذه العوامل قد تسبب
بانتشار الامراض خصوصا بين فئتي كبار السن
والاطفال هذا بالنسبه نعم عذرا على
المقاطعه محمد ولكن فقط له الامم المتحده
بالنسبه لمساله الحوامل كذلك التي يعني
يتطلب يعني يحتجن الى رعايه خاصه في ظل كل
هذه الظروف وطبعا جميعا نتذكر قصه الفتاه
التي ولدت حيه من امها التي
عنقاء سميت بعنقاء الزلزال
فيما يتعلق بهذه النقطه هل هناك اي
مساعدات مخصصه للنساء للحوامل او لحديثي
الولاده بعد الزلزال في ريف ادلب نعم يعني
في الحقيقه منطقه شمال غرب سوريا هي منطقه
يعني تعيش نوعا ما او الفئه الاكبر اكثر
من 90% من السكان المحليين والنازحين الى
هذه المنطقه يعيشون على المساعدات الامميه
سبق واستضفنا معنا يعني المتحدث الرسمي
باسم معبر باب الهوى وقال ان جميع
المساعدات التي دخلت عبر هذا المعبر هي
يعني
غير
مخصصه للزلزال انا هنا نتحدث عن الادويه
طبعا المنطقه بشكل عام تحتاج لمضاعفه
المساعدات الطبيه خصوصا يعني
لهذه الفئه التي نتحدث عنها وهي ف
الحوامل يعني خصوصا كما ذكرت لك قبل قليل
يعني المنطقه اكثر من 90% من السكان
المحليين او حتى المهجرين الى هنا يعيشون
على المساعدات الانسانيه
والكارثه الزلزال فاقمت الاوضاع سوءا سواء
كانت من حيث يعني نقص المساعدات الغذائيه
او حتى
نقص المساعدات الطبيه يعني
المنطقه بحسب العمال الاغاثيين او
الناشطون الاغاثيون قالوا بان المساعدات
التي دخلت الى حد هذه اللحظه لا تكفي
المنطقه ولا تكفي المتضررين نتيجه هذا
الزلزال خصوصا ان جميع المنظمات المحليه
يعني استنفذت مخصصاتها الشهريه في بدايه
هذه الكارثه عندما عملت للاستجابه الطارئه
لمتضرري
الزلزال طبعا ان تحدثنا قليلا وذكرنا بان
عدد مجموع الشاحنات
المحمله بالمساعدات الامميه التي عبرت عبر
معبر باب الهوى الى شمال غرب سوريا وصل
الى 175 شاحنه منذ بدايه هذه الكارثه حتى
هذه اللحظه شكرا جزيلا لك محمد الاشقر
مباشره من ريف ادلب عبر خدمه سكايب
[موسيقى]
نذهب الان الى ايران عاد النظام ليلف حبال
المشانق حول رقاب المحتجين ممن شاركوا في
التظاهرات الاخيره حيث اعدمت السلطات
القضائيه شابين من زاهدان التابعه
وهما نظام الدين حوت ومنصور حوت بعد توجيه
تهمه المعتاده وهي الافساد في الارض وهي
تهمه وفق قانون العقوبات الايراني عقوبتها
الاعدام مع العلم ان مرشد ايران كان قد
اعلن قبل اسابيع عفوا عاما بالافراج عن
الاف المعتقلين على خلفيه الاحتجاجات
الاخيره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا مشاهدينا باقصى وسائل الترهيب كالقتل
والاعدام يواجه النظام الايراني شعبه
واحتجاجاته المستمره منذ شهور على خلفيه
مقتل الشابه الكرديه مهسه امين على يد ما
تسمى بشرطه الاخلاق انذاك نظام الدين حوت
وكذلك منصور حوت وهما متظاهران ايرانيان
من البلوش اعتقلتهما قواته الحرس الثوري
الايراني في الثلاثين من سبتمبر الماضي
بعد احتجاجات شعبيه واسعه على خلفيه قيام
احد قاده الشرطه في مدينه شبهار باغتصاب
فتاه بلوشيه نقلت منظمات حالو رشعنا مصدر
مطلع تعرض منصور ونظام الدين حوت للتعذيب
الشديد اثناء اعتقالهما وتحت التعذيب اجبر
على الاعتراف واجبرا كذلك على التوقيع تحت
الضغط والتهديد من قبل المحققين الامنيين
في الاشهر الخ التي مرت منذ بدايه الحركه
الاحتجاجيه للمواطنين الايرانيين تم الكشف
عن حالات عديده من التعذيب والاعترافات
القصريه والتي لها تاريخ طويل في ايران
تقول حلوش كذلك انه تم اعتقال العديد من
المواطنين البلوش في زاهدان امس الاول وان
قوات الاستخبارات الحرس الثوريه الايراني
نقلتهم الى مكان مجهول وهذا ايضا بجانب
الاعتقال والاعدام هناك كذلك القتل ففي
الاشهر الخمسه الماضيه قتل مئات
المتظاهرين على ايدي قوات الامن والشرطه
واعتقل عشرات الالاف وذكرت منظمه حقوق
الانسان هانجا والكرديه اليوم الاحد ان
شابا يدعى مختار فتحي قتل بنيران مباشره
من القوات الامنيه في مدينه سقز التابعه
لمحافظه كردستان غرب ايران هذا الشاب اذا
هو من سكان مدينه سقفز وهي مسقط راس ماسه
اميني التي فجر مقتلها الاحتجاجات الحاليه
[موسيقى]
الله
اكبر
ونذهب الى سوريا الان مقتل واكثر من خمسه
عشر ايرانيا بينهم ضابطان في قصف اسرائيلي
يعتبر الثاني هذا العام على سوريا وفق ما
كشفته وسائل الاعلام السوريه معارضه هذه
المره القصف الاسرائيلي الطالب بشكل رئيسي
حي كفر سوسه في جنوب غربي دمشق واستهدف
مدرسه ايرانيه وشقه سكنيه كان يتواجد فيها
ضباط ايرانيون كانوا يعقدون اجتماعا سريا
في المنطقه مما ادى الى مقتل سته منهم ومن
بينهم ضابطان رفعاء المستوى بحسب المصادر
الهجوم الاسرائيليه مشاهدينا ايضا مواقع
الميليشيات الايرانيه في منطقه السيده
زينب
ومحيطي الفرقه الاولى في منطقه الكسوه
جنوب دمشق اسفر عن مقتل تسعه من عناصر
الميليشيات الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله
لم تتاخر بالرد لتوضح ان الهجوم
الاسرائيليه على دمشق استهدف عده مواقع
عسكريه ونفذ على مرحلتين الاولى في دمشق
في نفس الموقع الذي قتل فيه عماد مغنيه
اما الثانيه فكانت في السويداء نافيه وقوع
اضرار في مجمع للخميني او المدرسه
الايرانيه في دمشق اما الجانب السوري فاكد
الرقم نفسه وهو 15 قتيلا ولكنه غير هويه
القتلى مشيرا الى انهم مدنيون وبينهم
عسكري في حصيله هي الاعلى في العاصمه
السوريه نتيجه ضربه مماثله وفق ما افاد
المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان
[موسيقى]
هذا وبعد ساعات من الضربه الاسرائيليه على
دمشق حذر بن يمينه ياهو ايران من محاوله
ايذاء اسرائيل ومواطنيها مشددا على ان تل
ابيب لن تسمح لطهران بالتمركز على حدودها
الشماليه كما لن تسمح لها بامتلاك السلاح
النووي ايضا
ايران تحاول ايذاء اسرائيل ومواطنيها
اينما كانوا في العالم بلا هوادر هجمات
ايران لن تضبط عزيمه لن نسمح لايران
بامتلاك اسلحه نوويه ولا نسمح لها
بالتمركز على طول حدودنا الشماليه نفعل كل
شيء وسنبدو القصار جهدنا لحمايه مواطنينا
ونرد بشده على الهجمات ضدنا
اما في ردود الفعل الدوليه فاعتبرت
الخارجيه الروسيه الغارات الاسرائيليه على
دمشق انتهاكا للقانون الدولي
تصاعد ملحوظ للضربات الاسرائيليه على
اهداف في قلب العاصمه السوريه دمشق
استهداف صاروخي تخترق به اسرائيل الاجواء
السوريه بهدف الوصول لمواقع ومنشات
وعناصره تابعه لايران الاستهداف الثاني
خلال العام الجاري هجوم صاروخي اسرائيلي
طار كفر سوسه الحي السكني في دمشق وراحه
ضحيته 15 شخصا وفقا للمرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان تلك الصواريخ الاسرائيليه استهدفت
مواقع تتمركز فيها ميليشيات ايرانيه وحزب
الله اللبناني ويعد هذا الاستهداف
الاسرائيلي الثاني خلال العام الجاري ففي
الثاني من يناير الماضي قتل سبعه عناصر
جراء الضربات الاسرائيليه على مطار دمشق
الدولي ومحيطه
وتيره الهجمات الاسرائيليه على اهداف داخل
سوريا وثقها المرصد السوري بحوالي 32
استهدافا خلال العام الماضي وحده قامت
خلالها اسرائيل باستهداف الاراضي السوريه
سواء عبر ضربات صاروخيه او جويه اسفرت عن
اصابه وتدمير نحو 91 هدفا عسكريا
اذا مشاهدينا نذكر فقط بالاخبار العاجله
اذن التي وردت قبل قليل فيما يتعلق كذلك
بالتاهب الاسرائيلي الاعلام الاسرائيلي
يؤكد ان البحريه ترفع درجه الجاهزيه في
البحر الاحمر خوفا من اعتداء ايراني
وقبلها كنا تحدثنا على ما ذكره دبلوماسيون
بنسبه نقاء
84% في ايران نتابع من تل ابيب معنا يا
العليمه المحلل العسكري سيد اياد اهلا بك
معنا هل يمكن ادراج كل هذه الاخبار في
سياق الضربه الاسرائيليه على هذا الموقع
في دمشق
يبدو لي انه يمكن ادراج كل هذه الاخبار
بالتصعيد في المعركه مستمره بين اسرائيل
وايران نرى خلال
الاشهر والاسابيع الاخيره تصعيدا مستمرا
في هذه المعركه ربما تعرض السفينه لرجل
الاعمال
الاسرائيلي قبل حوالي اسبوع للقصبه
بالمسيرات الايرانيه ردا على
اتهمت ايران اسرائيل
بقصف المصنع في اصفهان وبالتالي هذه
الضربه الليله الماضيه التي كما ذكرت
واسعه النطاق من ناحيه الحجم وكذلك ناحيه
الخسائر لا شك اننا نستطيع الحديث عن
تصعيد في هذه المعركه المستمره لكن سيد
اياد المقصد السوري تحدث على انه ربما جرى
تصفيه قيادي في هذه الضربه في دمشق هل
لديك اي معلومات اخرى من كان المستهدف من
هذه الضربه الاسرائيليه الجديده على دمشق
لا نعلم كما كانت هناك شخصيه او قائد معين
مستهدفه من خلال هذه العمليه كما تعلم
اسرائيل
لما تعقب باي شكل من الاشكال على هذه
الضربات المنسوبه لها ولذلك
مصدر الانباء تاتي عاده من الخارج سواء من
المعارضه او من جهات اخرى
بالعاده صحيح درجه العاده اسرائيل لا
تعترف بتوجيه هكذا ضربات ولكن هذه المره
يعني بعد بعد ساعات من هذه الضربه بنيامين
نتنياهو صرح وتوعد ايران بانها لن تسمح
لها بالتموضع على حدودها الا يعد هذا كذلك
يعني اعترافا ضمنيا من اسرائيل بانها
مسؤوله عن ذلك على خلاف المرات السابقه
بالنظر ربما الى التهديد الذي كانت تواجهه
من ايران هذه المره
لا اعتقد يبدو ان هذه التصريحات اصبحت
تقليديه واعتياديه وفي الواقع تعبر عن
سياسه اسرائيل فيما يتعلق بمنع التموضع
الايراني في الاراضي السوريه ربما هذا ما
يبرر المعركه التي تخوضها اسرائيل خلال
السنوات الاخيره او ما يطلق بالمعركه ما
بين الحروب وراء هذه المعركه النظريه او
الفكره التي عبر عنها الرئيس الوزراء
نتنياهو اليوم طيب هناك شيء جديد ايضا في
هذه الضربه في دمشق هو التعقيب الروسي
والادانه شديده اللهجه من قبل روسيا هذه
المره ويعني ضد الضربه الاسرائيليه كيف
كيف تراها خاصه في ظل انه التفاهمات
الروسيه الاسرائيليه بشان سوريا وكذلك
التقارب الاسرائيلي ربما مع اوكرانيا في
الفتره الاخيره مع زياره وزير الخارجيه
كوهين الى كييف
الموضوع الروسي يقلق اسرائيل الى درجه
الحلسه بين طهران وموسكو من الناحيه
العسكريه التعاون التنسيق ولكن من الجانب
الاخر هناك ايضا التفاهمات بين اسرائيل
وروسيا التي تمكن سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي من
حريه حريه شبه مطلقه في الاجواء
مواصله هذه العمليات في الفتره الاخيره
قال مصدر عسكري اسرائيلي كبير انه في هذه
المرحله لا توجد قيود من قبل الجيش الروسي
على النشاط الاسرائيلي ولكن هذا الموضوع
يثير قلق اسرائيل ويؤخذ بنظل اعتبار ان
تلجا روسيا في نهايه الامر ربما الى تغيير
سياستها فيما يتعلق بهذا الموضوع هذا جمله
يبرر ايضا سياسه اسرائيل فيما يتعلق
بالحرب في اوكرانيا
العليمه شكرا لك من تل ابيب
[موسيقى]
وقعت الحكومه السودانيه وحركات المسلحه
على صيغه محدثه لتنفيذ اتفاق جمل السلام
بحضور رئيس المجلس الانتقاليه عبد الفتاح
البرهان ورئيسي جنوب السودان في الفكر
مليارديت امن الصارم بمخرجات هذه الورشه
ونحن على قناعه بان المصفوفه الجديده
ستشكل دافع عن قويه لتنفيذ ما تبقى من
بنود الاتفاقيه صغن الله وسدد خطه الجميع
للايفاء بالالتزامات والمطلوبات
هذا المساء مستمرا نتابع بعد الفاصل على
راسها البيتكوين سوق العملات المشفره
تستمر في الارتفاع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اوضحت جنرال الامريكيه
تشانس ان ما سماه سباق التسلح المضطرد في
الفضاء شهد تحولا جوهريا مضيفا خلال مؤتمر
ميونخ للامن بان الصين اصبحت تشكل تهديدا
كبيرا امام روسيا في مجال التسلح الفضائي
واشار الجنرال الذي يعمل قائدا لعمليات
الفضاء في سلاح الجو الامريكي ان خصومه
امريكا الاستراتيجيين يمتلكون مجموعه
كامله من الاسلحه وعلى راسهم الصين وروسيا
وفي اخبار الفضاء ايضا وبعد اكتشاف خلل في
عملها تخلصت مؤسسه روس كوسموسا روسيه من
مركبه
بروجرس ام اس 21 واكدت ان حطامها سقط في
المحيط الهادئ بعد فصلها عن المحطه
الفضائيه الدوليه وبعد مغادره المركبه
للمحطه قام رواد الفضاء بتحويلها والتقطوا
صورا اضافيه لموقع الخلل
دعا رئيس الوزراء السويديه في مقابله
لصحيفه فاناشيل تايمز دعا الى الموافقه
المتزامنه على طلبات بلاده وفنلندا
للانضمام الى حلف النيتو بحجه ان الدخول
المنفصله سيؤثر سلبا على امن المنطقه
والحلف باكمله كما حذر كريسترسون من عواقب
عدم تصديق تركيا على عضويه السويد قبل
انعقاد قمه حلف شمال الاطلسي في يوليو من
العام الجاري
[موسيقى]
في سوق العملات المشفره استمرت سلسله
الارتفاعات على اغلب العملات خاصه عمله
البيتكوين مع ارتفاع شهيه المستثمرين
للمخاطره على الرغميه من تحركات الماليه
الرقابيه الامريكيه استهدفت اساس هذه
السوق وهي العملات المشفره المزيد في
التقرير التالي
بعد الارتفاعات الكبيره لسوق العملات
المشفره في يناير والتي تجاوزت الاربعين
في المئه لعمله البيتكوين المحرك الرئيس
لهذه السوق يبدو ان زخم هذه الارتفاعات لم
يهدا بعد على الرغم من توجهات رقبيه وعلى
راسها الامريكيه بتضييق الخناق على هذا
السوق ففي الايام الاخيره امر كل من هيئه
الاوراق الماليه والبورصات واداره الخدمات
الماليه في ولايه نيويورك ان واي دي اف اس
شركه باكسوس المرخصه بوقف اصدار عمله بي
يو اس دي المستقره والتي تتبع اكبر منصه
تداول في العالم
هجوم السلطات الرقابيه الماليه جاء بحجه
تصنيف هذه العمله على انها ورقه ماليه غير
مرخصه وهذا ما قد يفتح الباب واسعا امام
تصنيف جميع العملات المستقره كاوراق ماليه
وفي هذه الحاله فان اس اي سي المسؤوله عن
تنظيمها بل وايقافها في حال مخالفتها
قواعد الهيئه ما ان جاء القرار بايقاف
باكسوس وعمله بي يو اس تي حتى دفعت الثمن
سريعا بتراجع عملتها بي ان بي تراجعا
حاديا تجاوز خمسه عشر في المئه لكن
المؤسسه سيزي غرد سريعا لانقاذ الموقف
وتوضيحه بان باينانس قد تبحث عن عمله
مستقره اخرى بعيدا عن الولايات المتحده
لضمان العمليات والعملاء وهو منعكس على
وقف نزيف بي ام بي على الاقل في الوقت
الحالي استهداف السلطات الرقابيه الماليه
للسوق الكريبتو هذه المره جاء بنتائج
عكسيه فحظر عمله بي يو اس تي دفع
المستثمرين الى تحويل حيازتهم فيها الى
عمله مشفره اخرى امن منها وبالطبع كانت
عمله البيتكوين افضل الخيارات بجانب عمله
يو اس دي تي المستقره وهو ما دعم
الارتفاعات
على البيتكوين تحرك سوق العملات المشفره
يعتمد على شهيه المخاطره للمستثمرين وهو
ما دعمه ارتفاع الاسواق الماليه وتراجع
التضخم وتخفيف الاحتياطي الفيدرالي للهجته
في رفح اسعار الفائده لكن السلطات
الرقابيه ما زالت ترى بان تنظيم السوق على
راس اولوياتها وذلك لمحاربه السرقه وغسيل
الاموال شادي الزعيم العربيه
[موسيقى]
من العملات المشفره الى شيء من الصحه كشفت
جميع توستان فورد ان هناك علاجا واعدا
لبعض امراض السرطان عبر الحمض النووي
بعيني الذي يرتبط بالجينات المسببه للمرض
نتابع
[موسيقى]
بهذا نصل الى ختام نشره التاسعه اليكم
تذكيرا بابرز عناوينها
اداره بيض تربك اوكرانيا تطالبها بهجوم
مضاد ضد روسيا وتبلغها باحتمال انقطاع
المساعدات العسكريه عنها
تفقده اثار زلزال في تركيا بلينكين يؤكد
العقوبات لن تؤثر على وصول المساعدات
للسوريين
النظام الايراني يعيد نصب المشانق لقمع
المحتجين ويعدم معتقلين بلوشيين من زاهده
وبعد ساعات من الضربه على دمشق نتنياهو
يحذر طهران لن نسمح بوجودكم على الحدود
الشماليه لاسرائيل
مشاهدينا اخبار التاسعه انتهت ولكن الفتره
المسائيه مستمره على العربيه بعد قليل
الزميل طاهر بركه اذا والعربيه 300 طاهر
مساء الخير هذه اول مره ساسمسلمك انا
بتسلمني وبرجع بسلمك بعد ساعه عندك ساعه
بس
نلتقي لاحقا ان شاء الله